uh what's uh do we have a name for the
EP y'all going to hear the name when it
come out it's just going to come out
like it's not even going to be no
preparation it's just going to drop
right no it's just going we're just
going to wake up it's going to be out
wake up it's yall think y'all a Beyonce
or
something
[__] who do y'all think y'all are like
y'all a go promote your [__] like it's
just going to come out like we're
Beyonce that's what we are y'all ain't
there yet give me a date no wow how you
going to do me huh it's just going to
drop man so since you guys have uh been
doing a lot more better in
life what's the stupidest purchase for
each of you so
far um I buy a lot of stupid [__] n yeah
I believe you I try to save my money but
you try to save your well okay for
someone who tries to save their money
what is a dumb purchase for you though m
I don't know do you ever like uh [__]
off on a chick's only fans content I
bought the only fans before where my
mother so when you bought the only fans
did you buy the content to go like like
the little
DM what they got DM content oh I bought
Tinder gold recently y on Tinder not say
oh you got Tinder gold I only bought it
to see like what it was like like so
back in the day when I was on Tinder I
had that too cuz you could do like
unlimited swipes right yeah you you
unlimited Swip so you can like unlimited
you can like unlimited what about I mean
if you're on Tinder without Tinder go
you cannot you got you got to wait you
got a unlimited amount of swipe like and
[__] that's my thing is if you're going
to be on Tinder you got to go gold
there's no reason to you your Tinder if
you're not gold yeah cuz then I don't
think it's a reason to be on here the
thing if you're on Tinder gold then you
just swipe on everything you're not even
looking you're just like this and then
you just see who you match with that she
looks rough there's a kid with her in
the picture I'll be I'm married now but
you know before I was married I had
Tinder gold and it was nice you was
getting [__] off there I got a few
you don't think that shut the back door
the back door like
anal Y no what do you say in the back
door who haven't like at least her what
does that mean yo but what what's the
back door what are you
saying but why does everything like the
anal that's what usually when you say
the back door that's what I mean that's
your [__] right cuz yo all
right what do you mean bro the back door
48 like the 48 like your set up oh you
think tinder's a setup you know I
actually heard if you go to like uh
certain countries Colombia if you go to
Colombia and you T they go They're Gonna
rob you for sure take you to the goog
[__] I've heard think if a [__] seen
Tata all the on Tinder hey hey can we
look at your Tinder profile right now
Tata while we're here I just want to see
what photos you're
using N I want to see what photos you're
using we got to rate these
pictures I'm just curious you don't not
on Tinder how [__] on what do you
want you got a bumble bum let me see let
me see I
got wait I got to see oh wow hold on
this is the one right here chrisan
mingle bro this is amazing just asking
to get robbed hold on I'm hey I'm going
to take a picture of this so we can put
it up on the screen right now this
picture of you flipping the camera off
with your teeth and like what looks to
be like Soulja Boy like
sunglasses bro what kind of matches are
you getting with these photos everything
no you're not getting any wifey material
with these there's no wife material
coming with those tring to tell her bro
like how is no wife material coming with
that bro oh you're you got the [__]
Astro Boy boots on we bro so what kind
of women are you matching with like show
the women
though some sexy Reds matching with you
for sure oh you got some Asians oh
Asians yeah what's your uh your favorite
uh type of Queen to
poach huh what is your favorite type of
Queen to poach poach I like tall girls
tall girl what's the heaviest Queen
you've ever poached no no no we don't do
no heavy we don't do no like I'm not
saying if you heavy you're not a
queen black is beautiful I but what's
the heaviest Queen you've
poached bro nothing over one 180
no what hey hey 130 130 okay okay 180
depending on hey also depending on
height
135 [__] bro 140 140 is over my [__]
be dumb thick dumb thick 180 is dumb
thick trying to show especially way goes
to the ass how tall or short is she I
don't really like tall [__] for me so
you like short 180 lb women so your
women all look like uh pinky eight
pinky what wait about wait who's that
yo Jen what kind of women do you like I
mean I just like women that respect
themselves that's a sweet answer none of
these [__] respect
theel these dumb ass
hoes talk about what's it like hanging
out with these misogynistic human beings
every day you're not
massag what the [__] that mean he said
[__] these [__] [__] these
[__] are you I don't find myself with
too many females cuz I don't trust them
I respect that is it is it chilling
though you be chilling yeah is it um
hard for you guys to trust women being
kind of famous I would trust no it's
even like harder I don't trust
nobody hard these [__] is [__]
bro that's good right for you they're if
they're [__] that's good yeah I don't
really give a [__] yeah damn we got to
get
Kyle you just got to you got to accept
the fact that feel me these hoes are
[__] man yeah everybody everybody the
Bros the Bros have you you are you guys
Eskimo brothers F that mean you and you
what the [__] that mean you want to know
yeah an esimo brother means you guys
have each poached the same Queen before
oh come on now yeah
going lie es Bros times how many I got
mutuals with like all my brothers I so
how many uh how many women in the world
have you guys each been inside of not at
the same time of course I just mean
overall
like like I got homies around a little
too Federal my heart I think I got a
list a list at least like three right
three to seven
three I got a list not going to lie you
have a list what is your list list I
tried to have a list they got I got a
list is had a list of all the women forg
bro right about that right after feel me
they go they can added to the list wait
so after you [__] check cuz look
there's a there's a serious list here I
just saw serious notes she list bro he's
got a real list with like real notations
list bro what am I do I got a list what
about dead check you out every time it's
they get added right to the list so and
I put a put like one one out of 10 in
parentheses wow any sort of specific
note like uh Asian girl if it was yeah
Asian girl Tinder if I don't remember
their name if I don't know their name I
put your lightskinn shorty from wherever
she from Upper East Side white [__]
eight out of 10 and if I just got the
neck if I just got the neck I'm put a
Peres like only head head rating two out
of six yeah you can't count that if it's
only
high but they just get added on to the
list though like y want a list I wish
have you guys ever heard the song by
Nora just called it's called head no who
is Nora Nori norga hold on nor norga CNN
component norga how you how song go what
what what what [__] oo [__] t y
invaden y I think that's past all
generation definitely way before uh
godamn drink Champs how' I go nor bro
drink Champs he interviews rappers he's
the drunk old uncle that everyone loves
in Hip Hop I met that [__] in La yeah
no Nori stand for NWS On The Run
eating he had a song called head and it
was doggy style was my favorite position
until I switched it dead [__] got on
some head [__] give me some head you
know yeah getting head in the whip
without crashing it you know I love that
have you guys ever gotten roadhead D
about that in a Lamborghini you got your
dick suck while driving a Lamborghini N
I was in the back seat who was driving
my manager oh your manager [__]
D yo a lam back seats not very spacious
bro that [__] is not spacious at all
what about a thick ass [__] what about
that buck 80 she was n not really a bu
like she was cool 35 4 send me your IG I
got you I see what y'all doing